[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
richtig cooles Video und zwar gibt es
drei Bento Box Inspirationen und Rezepte
was ist überhaupt eine Bento Box das ist
dieses gute Teil hier zurzeit in
verschiedenen Ausführungen und es ist
wie so eine Lunchbox also eine
pausenbrotbox mit verschiedenen
Unterteilungen bei mir habe ich jetzt
zwei Unterteilungen und entsprechend
habe ich mir richtig coole Rezept
Inspiration für euch überlegt und es
kommt aus dem asiatischen Raum und vom
Gefühl her waren auch die Asiaten immer
schon so organisiert und haben auch
immer für die Arbeit oder für Schule und
etc immer so Bento Boxen vorbereitet ihr
kennt alle diese Videos wo es immer so
mega ästhetisch auch angerichtet wird
wir starten jetzt mit Bento Box Nummer
eins Bento Box Nummer 1 wird unter
anderem es kommen noch mehrere Sachen
also lass dich überraschen unter anderem
mit Apfelmuffins gefüllt und ich starte
jetzt direkt und schreibt euch alle ganz
von Mengenangaben wie immer unten in die
Infobox ich habe jetzt hier zimmerwarme
Butter die gebe ich jetzt hier direkt in
meine Schüssel mit Zucker und
Vanilleextrakt und dann rühre ich das 3
Minuten lange zu meinem Handrührgerät
und dann gebe ich die trockenen Zutaten
dazu
[Musik]
so bevor sie trockenen Zutaten
reinkommen werde ich fast das Ei
vergessen ist natürlich auch super
wichtig so das gebe ich jetzt einfach
mit dazu kurz unterrühren solange bis es
sich verbindet und dann können mehl
Backpulver und Zimt dazu wenn ihr keine
Zimt Fans seid könnt ihr das jetzt auch
einfach weglassen ich finde es passt
halt so zum Apfel
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die trockenen Zutaten
kurz untergerührt habt einfach noch ein
Apfel klein schnibbeln und mit zum Teig
geben ich habe den Ofen auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 180°c
und zeige euch in der Zwischenzeit was
noch so schönes in unsere leckere Bento
Box reinkommt
[Musik]
so neben den Apfel Muffins kommen noch
Wraps in die Bento Box und da habe ich
jetzt gedacht dass wir einfach auch so
ein cooles so eine ja nicht Dressing
Dressing wäre er für den Salat am
einfach so ein so eine coole Soße machen
die wir noch auf unserer in unsere tun
ja heute ist Montag müsst ihr wissen und
geht so richtig montagmäßig heute also
ich rühre jetzt Tahini um es sieht so
ein Tahini so eine Tahini Soße da rührt
ihr einfach nur ein paar Zutaten
zusammen bei Tahini ist es so es besteht
nur aus Sesam bei mir geschält und
geröstet jede Tahini schmeckt anders
habe ich festgestellt da habe ich auch
meine eigene gemacht weil einige
schmecken halt bitter und wichtig ist
dass ihr rührt weil oben befindet sich
das ganze Öl und dann müsste ständig
umrühren damit es wieder sämig sondern
kommt da ein bisschen was von der Tahini
einmal in unsere Schüssel und dann gebe
ich auch schon Olivenöl und Apfelessig
dazu
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch
Kreuzkümmel und Salz und Pfeffer mit
dazugegeben und das ist eine richtig
schöne würzige Soße entstanden und jetzt
nehme ich mir mein weiblichen immer den
den ich gerade da habe ich habe auch
mein Weizen Wraps da heute ist es eher
so ein Vollkorn wrap und jetzt machen
wir uns ein gemüsewrap drauf und dann
gibt jetzt einfach Eisbergsalat dazu und
eigentlich könnt ihr alles dazu geben
was ihr möchtet haben zum Beispiel auch
Gurken aber ich nehme heute Tomaten und
rote Paprika und dann kommt noch die
Tahini Soße drauf und dann wird das
einfach schön eingerollt und einmal
durchgeschnitten
[Musik]
zum snacken habe ich hier jetzt noch ein
paar Cherrytomaten in die obere Bento
Box gelegt und unten kommen jetzt die
fertigen Apfelmuffins rein und dann
würde ich auch schon sagen gehen wir
über zum nächsten Bento Box sind die ist
asiatisch angehaucht
[Musik]
für Bento Box Nummer zwei brauchen wir
Sushi Reis denn wir machen ein Sushi
Sandwich und dafür einfach den Sushi
Reis unter fließendem Wasser ein
bisschen waschen damit die Stärke so ein
bisschen rauskommt und das nicht zu
pampig wird dann mit kochendem Wasser 2
Minuten dann köcheln lassen anschließend
runter auf die mittlere Stufe und das
Wasser verdunsten lassen solange bis man
den Reis wieder sieht und anschließend
weitere 20 Minuten einfach nur garen
selbst ist der Reis fertig gegangen hat
noch kein Geschmack und dafür nehmen wir
uns als Alternative zu Reisessig weil
man den halt auch nicht immer da hat
nehmen wir uns drei Zutaten die man
eigentlich immer zu Hause hat und zwar
Apfelessig Sojasauce jetzt gebe ich
Apfelessig auch schon direkt mit zu
Sojasauce
und Zucker und dann verrühren wir das
mit dem Reis und dann zeige ich euch wie
es weitergeht
[Musik]
so mein Sushireis ist fertig und ich
verrühre jetzt hier noch Thunfisch mit
Sushi Majo ist auch noch mal eine andere
Mayo als die die wir vom aus dem
deutschen Supermarkt kennen und dann ja
würde ich mal sagen nehmen wir uns
unseren Nori Blatt ihr könnt auch noch
anderes Gemüse mit dazu nehmen ich hatte
jetzt noch Paprika da oder ihr nehmt
auch einfach noch Salatblätter mit rein
also das ist einfach so eine neue
Interpretation das ist so schießt also
ich habe ja gleich nichts mit Tradition
zu tun und nebenbei habe ich noch
Edamame die werde ich mir gleich in der
Mikrowelle mit ein bisschen Wasser
einfach so ein bisschen
aufweichen die sind jetzt tiefgekühlt
und dann kommt danach Salz mit dazu das
Wasser müsst ihr aber unbedingt abgießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben jetzt soweit alles vorbereitet
und jetzt geht es fast ans befüllen ich
wollte aber gerne für die untere Box
noch etwas Süßes so als Nachtisch haben
und dann nehme ich einfach Naturjoghurt
süße das mit ein bisschen Honig
ihr könnt auch Agaven Dicksaft nehmen
oder vielleicht mögt ihr auch gar nicht
so süß dann könnt das weglassen aber ich
brauche immer süße zum Joghurt dann gebe
ich das direkt in die saubere Box gibt
da Früchte mit oben drauf und auch noch
Granola dann hat man noch so ein
bisschen was zu knabbern so und dann
geht's auch schon rüber zum nächsten Box
[Musik]
ich muss ehrlich zugeben dieses
Toastbrot hat Sarah gekauft für einen
anderen Zweck ne ich weiß gar nicht was
wir noch mal machen wollten und das war
so eine Packung und haben sie nicht an
die komplett aufgegessen bis auf zwei
Scheiben und wir machen unser Tagen das
was ich Euch jetzt zeige bei Eier mit
ein bisschen Milch verquälen und dann in
die Pfanne geben mit ein bisschen
Olivenöl ja gutes Olivenöl darf man auch
gut erhitzen da ist ja immer dieser
Mythos dass man Olivenöl nicht heißer
als ich glaube 200 Grad erhitzen sollte
ja das geht für schlechtes Olivenöl so
einfach in die rein und dann geben wir
das Ei rein sobald es auf Hitze gekommen
ist ich habe jetzt hier Stufe 7 von 9
und dann geben wir unsere Toastbrote mit
dazu aber wenn ihr noch mal den Kick
möchtet dann nehmt ihr euch
Paprikapaste es gibt der Paprikamark ihr
könntet auch Tomatenmark nehmen und
bestreicht das damit nochmal und dann
zeige ich euch gleich wie ihr noch mal
so eine richtig leckere sandwichsoße
machen könnt
[Musik]
ich habe unsere Creme jetzt einmal kurz
zusammengerührt wird auch gut zu Salat
fassen glaube ich jetzt gebe ich hier
noch mal Rührei Gewürz mit dazu weil
jetzt schmeckt sehr gerade noch nach
fast gar nichts einfach mit drauf so und
dann Käse eurer Wahl ihr könntet jetzt
auch Wurst oder Sucuk mit dazu geben ich
lasse es heute mal vegetarisch also in
dem Fall jetzt und dann die
Salatcreme mit dazu jetzt schon
Salatcreme aber ich habe die passt auch
richtig gut zu Salat
einfach mit drauf geben und anschließend
einfach nur noch umklappen und dann ist
es eigentlich auch schon fertig
so ich lasse das Toast jetzt mal von
beiden Seiten 3 Minuten lang Crosser
werden weil ich mag das einfach lieber
als wenn es weich ist und labbrig und
jetzt habe ich hier noch Salat Zutaten
nimmt am besten Zutaten die nicht ganz
so schnell durchwässern ich habe jetzt
hier feste Cherrytomaten das ist auch
das höchste der Gefühle ich glaube
ansonsten nimmt einfach am besten so
Sachen wie die Zwiebel oder Paprika und
das besser dann nicht so schnell durch
und dann gebe ich das auch direkt in die
untere Box und machen mir mein Standard
lieblingsdressing auch das schnellste
Dressing dass ich kenne aus Olivenöl
Granatapfelsirup und Salz
[Musik]
unser salädchen ist fertig und jetzt
kommt noch die obere Box meine Toast
sind jetzt auch von außen schön kross
guckt euch das mal
an ne
kommt jetzt einmal hier oben rein
das freut man sich doch auf die Pause
oder ob es in der Uni ist so
verarbeitende Schule so jetzt habe ich
ihn noch ein bisschen Platz und mir
fehlt jetzt noch was Süßes und natürlich
ist auch super sättigen da gebe ich
jetzt noch dattelbälle mit rein oberla
einfach von jeder Sorte so ein paar und
dann ist die Box auch fertig Leute drei
Bento Boxen wenn ihr das Video feiert
dann schreibt es mal in die Kommentare
und schreibt auch gerne mal rein welche
Box euch am besten gefallen und wisst
ihr was wer richtig treu ist und bis zum
Schluss dran geblieben ist dem schenke
ich eine Box macht einfach mit indem Ihr
schreibt welche Box euch am besten
gefallen hat und dann suche ich mir drei
Leute aus aber bleibt auf jeden Fall
noch dran denn dann seht ihr überhaupt
das Endergebnis von allen wenn du Boxen
und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis
zum nächsten mal auf meinem Kanal
tschüss
[Musik]